[Music]
in hypnotize students knitters so many
bye love you Geo from Milan where Malad
mi la did you make me feel good yeah I
made it out to do it I made it up funny
leave this isn't really submit of my
people okay sure
a teacher has been arrested after being
accused of trying to hypnotize students
why is that sexy cuz it's like you make
them do whatever you want
oh it says tried so I guess they failed
at it that's one of the sexiest things
that ever seen I don't know I heard 3rd
grade teacher maybe you should oh my
[ __ ] you imagine this a hairy 50 year
old man right who just got out of a
divorce he's [ __ ] horny and then he
has a classroom full of
fourteen-year-old girls cuz he works out
of Catholic school and he hypnotizes all
of them oh and he helps them all study
again good great because they never want
to do the homework there's a twist
BAM 4.0 everyone gets perfect scores on
the AP test and he goes home and jacks
off to himself your disgusting detail
because he's transferring his horny
energy into positivity because all 50
old men are just different aspects of
people's lives you know I was ready to
[ __ ] believe the situation no because
ithat's being like then these news
articles they get the tire these factors
that that you feel like make sense but
what they don't tell you are things that
don't make sense and that's what makes a
real person for example pedophiles
probably love breakfast burritos right I
don't know anyone that is like a
breakfast burrito I agree but they will
tell you these things a humanizes them
you gotta create monsters breakfast
burritos are always on the call sheet
for JK party just attempt Oliver and
they're never there teas are frozen
tell us those are eatable those are like
sandwiches they're like McMuffins like
Jimmy Dean oh my god put these facts in
to let you know this is a well-rounded
person he's horny but he also cares
about the future of little girls mmm
I don't think it's uh pedophilia right
oh don't think I think he hypnotizes too
far it is tip no pain so tip okay why is
all the news bad so the third grade
[ __ ] hater my third grade teacher
mrs. Clinton Burt [ __ ] you well that was
my favorite teacher all the time my
favorite mrs. Queen camber no mr.
Kirkpatrick I had mr. Chowdhury anxious
I had mr. noodle chin I had mystic seer
she have the dopest tits I've ever seen
ever seen in my life white anyway so the
third grade teacher 39 oh yeah from
Pennsylvania you reverse pedophile all
right little boys or overs pedophiles
they're like jailbait dude all little
boys 39 year old Pennsylvanian
third-grade teacher he would date you
would get students ages 8 9 and 11
what is a Montessori School bra
Elementary School why is he having like
three different ages in one classroom
tell me why you get so mad at the guy
I like yes thank you no one says it
enough I'm confused because I thought it
was all third graders no that's what I
thought fourth grade teachers - that
sounds like she's like a inch away from
clapping every word created I'll tell
you I'll tell you the news he's a third
grade teacher that liked to hang out
with the older kids just let her tell us
the news
Thank You Nikki so he would go to these
classrooms that will had substitute
teachers tell these substitute teachers
that he was working on a special project
with the certain girl they were all
girls these girls students and so they
would go over to his classroom he would
be filming them through a computer I
think he would have them play with
tablet or no or either a laptop computer
or an iPad he was recording them he
would have them read certain things
about communities from a packet and he
would record all this thing all these
things and so he would force them to say
certain things sometimes and when they
didn't say it a certain way
Oh cuz he had puppets so he had to they
had to say whatever they were reading
from these packets through the puppet
and they wouldn't say it as the puppet
he would get mad at them and yell at
them so he's just a shitty director so
that and there was a small more victim
who did say that he would rub her arm
and allegedly told her to call him her
master and he would swing a necklace in
front of her as he was trying to say I
will obey your commands master and and
one [ __ ] [ __ ] he was watching a
[ __ ] Animaniacs on a cartoon what was
that the the WB Looney Tunes Merrie
Melodies all about the sneeze my nose my
pocket watch just for this occasion -
yeah exactly
and it was so weird - because he would
make these victims look at certain
objects in the room and like look at my
swirly umbrella
very odd and she would like her teachers
really weird I move mints apparently one
victim he gave a crown to wear and a one
and a stuffed animal to hold in her hand
that's a victim well there was out of
all these victims there was one that did
report that he did touch her private
there we go
I was rooting for this guy when he was
giving him stuffed animals yeah but now
he's just a stupid as a pedophile oh
jesus [ __ ] christ his name is James
[ __ ] you James okay so from from the
nose up he looks like a normal guy okay
but from the nose down nah but he's like
a Lego from the nose down
I don't he looks like a walrus kind of
his chin looks like a knee like a really
hairy what's going on the amount of
space on his forehead to his chin exact
same this is made in like the rule of
thirds
yeah like forehead from [ __ ] eyebrow
to lips to try it's like three fingers
three fingers three fingers yeah big
mouth is just a flip they all head
that's a vagina mouth for sure kind of a
dry I would have been able to be
hypnotized by him I'd be too focused on
how [ __ ] ugly he is I wouldn't even
go I understand I can't do this project
okay but they're little kids yeah you
can't say no okay
any scary-looking so then yeah you felt
really five victims [ __ ] this dude but
only one of them sexual or all kind of
weird what he was trying to get there
dude yeah yeah cuz there might be more
that didn't report so he's been teaching
full-time at that school since 2003 oh
my ear dreams like the police are trying
to get other former students yeah yeah
how many [ __ ] you are getting sleepy
did he do obviously didn't do well if
they remember this [ __ ] yeah thank God
we're home how old they're like they
were like there was one eight year old
one nine year olds and three eleven year
old they're a little bit older then
third grade right what's third grade is
six or seven yeah almost reads like eat
I don't know [ __ ] about kids eight or
nine yeah I guess making numbers up he's
about to be in 15 he's ten pennies all
no yeah like when the victim was
describing the thing was he rubbed the
victims leg from her needs her groin
area ignoring her request to stop that's
pretty sad I don't think I was uh I
don't think I'm a pedophile horny cuz I
don't have any type of examples of
feeling feeling threatened you know like
that I was always looking for like a
older person to kind of hang out with
yeah yeah from like fourth grade like
high school I would have sex dreams
about the ugliest oldest teachers for
fourth grade yeah and I didn't like it
like oh my dreams but I would have
dreams
did you know what sex was like it was
censored yeah maybe nobody when when
you're naked in your dream to have foggy
share over your body my legs are just
like soap sites or like a sheep or it's
pixelated yeah it's just bare shoulders
it's probably good actually those black
bars naked I just
Highschool ones were sex dreams because
I knew what it was but then but in the
early days it was just like we were both
naked and he was just like on top of me
but like I yeah the penis went in the
vagina he saw a penis though to like
yeah dream of yeah a buddy mine told me
that sex was you put your dick in a girl
but then you pee inside her fur the
inside of her and so my sex dreams were
just me and urinating and like too long
for too long Wow for a long time that's
a new boy you're just being your bed in
real life I didn't wet the bed you
didn't I mean I did more than once yeah
did you really oh sure I wet the bed
you never with the bed Bennis no I'm
saying if you've wet the bed because of
the dream oh no no I didn't do this
wetting the bed was pretty dope though
it feels good yeah in the dream and when
you wake up and it's cold you got to
tell your mom you get in trouble and you
just clean up dreams when I'm looking
for toilets and like even when I find a
toilet and I still have to pee because
you're not peeing in real life so I'm
like I'm like peeing in my dream but I'm
not being realized like why do I still
have to pee all day you're lucky a temp
in Rome because I've had in my adulthood
now like I have to pee and I dream that
I find a toilet and have to in my dream
I remember no don't pee you're gonna be
in real time and then I wake up and go
that's good you knew it's a dream I was
hoping that would end differently I know
I was hoping you peed your company like
Oh fine I can empty my bladder finally
and he wake up and in case he's all up
in it yeah no we haven't wet the bed do
you ever dream where you orgasm in your
dream and you orgasm really yeah okay
but I mean you guys are talent but I
have only done it like when I'm having
sex with retreat
I think so like why do you talk this
hall or was it more like one time Paris
Hilton Paris Hilton you were humping her
yeah like you were like rubbing her like
you rub this resin scissoring we weren't
naked it just was like yeah kind of just
dry humping what did it look like
oh no I just like connection you guys
make out at all early no does she like
yeah what kind of tree did you [ __ ] I
don't know it was like I was stuck over
a river and I was like holding on to
this tree was it Ohio I was just rubbing
in the right way it was it was known as
a big old tree this is where we're not
getting plastered nothing ever goes in
me when I come in my dream it's like I'm
rubbing against a spiritual [ __ ] it's a
spiritual rub yeah
[Music]